okay
hello hi lindsay i'm very happy i'll let
you have a glass of water because you're
going to be doing a lot of talking i'm
very happy to be able to talk to lindsey
dao of lindsay does languages and maybe
you can start by explaining
what it is that you do
ah okay thank you very much steve hello
um so i'm lindsay as you've said and so
what i do is quite a mixture of things i
teach languages i teach english french
and spanish
but i also learn them myself that's
that's my main passion is the learning
side of things um right now i'm learning
korean and trying to keep up a little
bit of japanese as well and i recently
actually finished esperanto on duolingo
which is which is uh quite interesting
because i started it a lot later than
those languages yeah i feel so much more
advanced already which goes to show
the whole no language is created equal
theory
for the learner but yeah i also on
lindsay does languages i blog i make
videos about language it's pretty much
everything
in my life language language language
okay we'll leave a link in the
description box here to the video so
people can come and visit you
um now question first of all let me say
that uh having learned a bunch of
languages
that languages are not equal in terms of
their level of difficulty as you say and
it all depends on the language we start
from
but i'm finding korean
a challenge even though i speak chinese
and i speak japanese
korean is difficult
and we can get into that later on
perhaps in the discussion what makes a
language difficult and no question that
after russian and uh
czech then ukrainian becomes easier
for french speakers spanish people so
they're not all equally difficult no
question
but my my question is this i think we
have a tendency to think of
english-speaking countries as countries
where and that includes of course the uk
canada and so forth
countries where people are less
interested in learning other languages
either because they're less intelligent
which is probably not the case
most people are equally intelligent on
average or because they just don't feel
the need
whereas people in countries and
typically people from smaller countries
uh from smaller languages feel on a
greater need to learn and if you go to
japan or russia or
i don't know spain
mind you the germans are pretty good so
the question is this
how keen are people in the uk
on learning languages is a big part of
your job trying to motivate them or are
there a lot of motivated people who just
need your help
that's a very good question and it's
something i always thought of from the
beginning is
i mean when i before i did lindsay's
languages i worked in a secondary school
and i was a learner support assistant
primarily in the language department and
i would take out small groups um to
teach them you know if they
wouldn't pick up as much in the class
we'd teach them a certain rate by myself
um and
it was always a challenge in the sense
that within the main classroom within
the main language classroom in secondary
school and bear in mind this is a lot of
the time this was the first exposure
people had had to languages in primary
school when i was working in in in
schools it wasn't complexity i think it
was in 2014 they actually made it
compulsory to learn
a language in primary school and it's a
very interesting thing is that it's
actually very open they say any language
living or dead they have to learn a
language and a different language to
english within primary school which is
really
interesting because it then creates this
this difference that you have then when
people then go to secondary school and
they start
with generally french or spanish
occasionally german maybe something else
and
it was the same problem when i was
that age as well
i'd had french club in primary school
as a kind of extracurricular thing but
then going to secondary school you start
from the beginning because you're coming
from all these different theory schools
and no one knows where they're at and
so the teachers then have this quite
difficult job granted of trying to bring
everyone to the same point but the
problem what happens there is you're 11
years old and your teachers are talking
to you as if you're full
that you know they're
dog cat green blue all of that stuff and
it's taught in a very primary manner
very simplistic
you know you go into mathematics and
you're learning kind of trigonometry for
the first time and then in first you're
still learning i like football and i
think that's a big reason um
is the sort of education side of things
this you know the kind of
um official education side of things is
that it's not very
inspiring perhaps and that's by no means
the fault of teachers there's some
fantastic language teachers out there
but then also as you say
coming from an english-speaking country
where
the need is
seen as less
you know
yeah go ahead i'm just going to say a
couple of reactions if you're in sweden
most kids by the time they reach
secondary school they already speak
english because they've been watching uh
english language television programs
english language movies listening to
english pop music and so forth
so
and another thing too is i often
question the
you know the relative importance of the
classroom versus other factors
and i'll give you another example in my
grandchildren are in french immersion
french immersion in canada is just a
situation where english-speaking kids in
a place like vancouver where there's no
french speakers to speak of
they do all their schooling in french
the late immersion kids who start in
grade seven or grade eight
they catch up right away
so they're in a classroom studying you
know history chemistry whatever it might
be
maybe getting a little extra help but
they're doing everything in french
and they're in there with a group of
kids who started doing this from grade
one and they catch up right away
so so it's interesting so it gets back
to your point maybe in high school in
britain instead of teaching them this is
a dog
if they actually gave them something
that was more challenging to do and more
interesting they might advance more
quickly
yeah i couldn't agree anymore i i
completely agree with that i mean like i
mentioned briefly that now it's
compulsory in primary school and it's
very open let's say you know you learn a
language so you
primarily it's going to be
french it's going to be spanish
um but you know you've got companies
that will go that will teach there's one
company i think they're called
springboard to languages and they teach
esperanto and their whole kind of ethos
is well in primary school kids learn the
recorder not to create a nation of
recorded players but to create kids that
understand
the basics of music and you know they
teach esperanto with that mindset of
this isn't so that everyone speaks
esperanto it's so that people are
exposed and from a young age to other
languages and i think that is
what's needed and that is hopefully
what's now beginning to change in the
last couple of years with that
introduction now question if the kids in
primary school can choose any language
then
one of the options like i'm in favor of
giving kids choice like i'm against the
idea that in canada say in vancouver
everyone has to learn french even though
french is an official language the
reality is they will probably not have
much use for french and if they're more
motivated to learn chinese or spanish
why wouldn't they be able to learn that
language the counter argument from the
schools always is we don't have
qualified
accredited teachers in that language and
my answer always is there's so many
resources available it doesn't matter if
you have a motivated language coach
who knows how to help kids access all
this stuff so what do they do in britain
how do they deal with this fact the kid
says okay i want to learn japanese the
school says we don't have a japanese
teacher then what
that's pretty much what happens so then
so then the kids weren't gay still in
japanese
you know
it is it is still that basis of
um for example my my partner is a
primary school teacher and so they have
french at their school they have a
french teacher who comes in i think one
day a week and teaches each class one by
one their french lesson for the week
and that's how that's just that's the
way it goes um you do get
it maybe that a teacher that already
works at the school speaks i don't know
or studied latin for example when they
were at school
30 40 years ago and they oh i've got
some latin you know and then they might
teach latin if the school can't find an
external teacher to to come in and do it
so there are occasions where it would
vary like that but it's very rare i
think that the child would get the
choice
again like you say because you said you
said they were allowed to choose
whatever they wanted oh no the school
the school is allowed to choose oh this
school is allowed to choose see i'm
again it always annoys me that
everything that happens in language
learning is dictated by the teacher
uh let's say that you had
uh a skill like within the teaching
profession you had people who
knew where to find resources on the
internet let's take japanese so there
are going to be children in the uk who
are interested in anime who are
interested in some aspect of japanese
culture even at the age of ten those
people exist
and so if initially let's say that
the initial course was to start to show
them some of the things they can do in
different languages which might be
swahili might be japanese might be
russian whatever
and then the kid says i'm interested in
japanese then the teacher just say well
here are some resources that you can use
that you can listen to that you can do
stuff with and maybe there's you have to
pool
uh you know the human resources within
the teaching community
so that the teacher at school a is a
coordinator coach motivator but she's
able to access some other more specific
resources japanese language resources
that are available in
yorkshire or you know somewhere that
somehow
because i come across this here again if
we don't have a teacher in our school
who can teach japanese
you can't have japanese which in today's
day and age strikes me as very backward
looking
i think that's a fantastic point and i
love that idea of having someone who
gives the child the reason because
everything now is it's
it's so much easier like you say with
the internet and everything it's so easy
as well for a child a child picks up an
ipad and they know exactly what to do
with it
you know so if you if you've got a
japanese app installed on the ipad the
child is going to know exactly what to
do and they're going to learn japanese
so
yeah it is so easy it should be
it should be the case that that you know
the child can say i want to learn this
language i'm intrigued by that you know
i love this aspect of that culture i
love that food or just something small
that they've picked up on even from a
young age that they can then draw on and
learn a language from and
i think i would like to think that that
is something that will
change i mean it's something i've always
i've always felt like you asked at the
beginning
um is it a case of
the students in the uk already there or
am i kind of having to motivate and i've
always
felt very passionate about the idea of
inspiring language learning with what i
do
and and i hope that that comes across i
hope that that
there's always this sort of dilemma on
the one hand
sort of the the learner-centered
approach says
that the kids or the learner not just
kids should have the freedom to choose
what to learn how to learn but the
reality is that most people don't want
that degree of freedom most people like
to be directed
so and yet if it's too i always find
like
as a learner when the teacher here you
have to you have to read this story you
know and then you have to answer my
questions on this story and so
everything we're dancing to the tune
that's dictated by the teacher so there
has to be some kind of balance between
freedom allowing you know people being
motivated by what interests them and
then
you know the fact is that it's it's like
the teacher is a shepherd well you have
the the you know you have the laggards
so they need to be shepherded you know
heard it along with the others so some
kind of a more of a role of motivator
coordinator providing some guidance and
direction but where possible you know
allowing people to do what they what
they want to do rather than forcing them
which gets me the subject of esperanto
i'm not a fan of
you know some people say well if you
learn latin then you can learn the other
romance languages and i would say why
not start with spanish because it's more
interesting than latin for most people
unless you're interested in ancient rome
and so i personally because i have yet
to meet an esperant you know resident of
esperantia
um i'm more motivated to learn another
language
and then every with every language you
learn of course you get better at
learning languages
so maybe esperanto is faster but the
effort you put into learning spanish
russian korean is also going to prepare
you
for them learning other languages so i
think esperanto should be part of the
mix but i wouldn't like to see a
situation where the school says okay in
primary school everyone does esperanto
because we think that's good
i would not be in favor of that that's
very interesting
and you know the only reason i learned
esperanto was i met some friends
probably last year
that spoke esperanto
i then found a book
last year and i thought oh this is kind
of falling into my lap yeah and it was
on duolingo and i was like let's give
joel and go again let's see how this
goes
and that was that was it there was there
was no and but as i was going through
the course there were things like um you
know
i would i would like to order
a pizza or whatever and you're thinking
i would never be in a situation where
i'm in a restaurant
and me and a waiter or a waitress the
only common language i have is esperanto
when's that gonna happen because you
know it's like you say there's even yet
to make me a native speaker of esperanto
and of course they're you know there are
native speakers now well
probably not just now probably over the
past few decades even but yeah i did
find that as i was working i'm thinking
this is cool and it's very interesting
that i'm picking this up and it's a new
language
it's happening so fast but i couldn't
see
uh an opportunity in my life when i
would use it which was which was curious
well i mean for example it depends how
we're motivated and i mean if i hear a
foreign language around me my ears you
know
i
prick
up
go over there and see if i can talk to
them or if i'm on an airplane i'm always
hoping the person sitting beside me will
be you know a speaker of some other
language
and now for example with my ukrainian
i've been
listening to some really interesting
stuff about ukrainian history in
ukrainian and i did the same with polish
and it doesn't matter chinese i mean
when i started learning chinese you get
involved in this whole
phenomenal world
of china and its history and stuff like
that
so to that extent you know
it may be that i could learn esperanto
very quickly but i'm just not motivated
however for those who are motivated
that's fine all i'm saying is to impose
that as the sort of all kids shall learn
esperanto in the primary school system i
would not be personally i wouldn't think
that would be such a great idea you know
i can i can i can see i can see that i
can see why
now let's move on a bit to by the way
yeah you have experienced duolingo
you should get on link sometime and work
on your korean for example
although korean is a tough one on link
because what i find so difficult in
korean is there's so many words that
have so many different meanings i looked
them up in my neighbor dictionary and
i'm no further ahead in fact i'm uh we
have a korean girl in the office uh
for three months here we have this link
academy live where we got a learner from
taiwan a learner from korea and learning
from hungary and we're interacting with
them and working on their english and
stuff and she's going to help me with my
korean and i've got a list of words that
i've saved in link where the dictionary
the neighbor which is an excellent
dictionary it provides no clue at all as
to what the meaning is oh wow and i find
that in other languages the dictionary
is pretty good you know depending on
which language you'll find the
dictionary that you like the best and we
link up to it at link and i'm i'm
working my way through the text and i
understand it but korean to that extent
is
is more more difficult so
yeah it is it's
yeah because you know you do feel that
kind of
well i've learned this language so now
it's it's going to be easy from here on
in i've learned x number of languages
now you know i know what i'm doing now
but yeah
korean has been interesting
i don't
i don't know i don't i'm aware to say
the hardest language i've ever learned
because i always kind of hold back to
german because at the time when i
learned german everything before had
been a romance language and then all of
a sudden it was like cases i'm thinking
hang on a minute what is the case and it
it really took a long time for me to
get my head around that concept
um but then once i got it it was easy so
maybe in that sense korean is now taking
taking over german as that title for me
of the hardest one that i've that i've
looked at
can i ask what your motivation was to
learn korea
to learn korean so
i have a friend shannon
who has a language blog and we wanted to
learn a language together
and she had some resources for korean i
have nothing i have i'm going completely
from uh sort of free resources that are
available where she's got some books and
and dictionaries and all this stuff so
it's kind of this interesting contrast
so we wanted to learn it together she
lives in california it's on the other
side of the world so it's a nice
way that we can connect and
study together in that sense
yeah i mean i in my career in the case
of uh i mean we have some beginner
material at link and then i went to talk
to me in korean
material available are you familiar with
talk to me in korean yes yeah yeah it's
very good so i used a bunch of that now
a lot of our members have contributed
content in our library in korean and
then
as i advanced in korea and i needed
something a little more with some more
substance so i found two podcasts which
i paid a lady to transcribe
so i'm now learning uh from those but
they're just a little difficult for me
so i struggle to find something that's
kind of
intermediate even slightly advanced
intermediate and and yet interesting and
so i think a large part of
learning any language if i like with
ukrainian i found all this interesting
stuff about ukrainian history and the
same with russian and czech and so forth
so part of it is finding interesting uh
material because that'll motivate you to
fight your way through
all the vagueness and uncertainty and
stuff like that definitely definitely i
think one of the one of the big mistakes
i made was
when i started japanese i started with a
tutor straight away and it was a
fantastic tutor i learned so much i was
able to
kind of put together really kind of
basic sentences and then questions and
it expanded and and generated
for learning languages
yeah so i thought with korean i thought
i'll do the same thing i'll get a
tutorial early on i'll get a sort of
speaking
it will work we spent about seven eight
lessons on pronunciation and i was bored
to tears i'm not someone that can study
pronunciation for a prolonged period of
time so
i made that mistake in that from the
beginning
it became
not as fun so i had to then kind of
almost shake things up and restart and
make it fun and find things that that
did work for me so i think i'm getting
there now
in that sense see that's interesting my
approach is i'm going to have so much
trouble pronouncing at the beginning
that i don't worry about
trying to pronounce or trying to say
anything
until my brain has become much more
familiar with the language because
the fact the matter is we don't hear the
pronunciation we don't hear it how can
we possibly reproduce it if we can't
hear it
and it's interesting the reason i know
we don't hear it is like one of the
functions we have at link is we have
dictation where if you save a bunch of
phrases you can then review these
phrases
uh one by one and sort of cards and and
there's text to speech so then you hear
it then you gotta type it out in polish
and what i thought i heard and what was
actually said were two different things
so you we really have to train ourselves
to actually hear what's said bef in my
view before we can hope to be able to
pronounce it and so once we hear it
better then we have a better chance of
pronouncing it correctly so normally i
will don't even i don't even worry about
pronunciation until several months and
and i
don't really worry that much about
output until i have built up a certain
amount of vocabulary
and to that extent even the cases
say with german or russian
there's
normally there's sort of a a redundancy
of words so that in most situations you
can figure out the meaning like 70
percent 80 percent
clearly somewhat vaguely without really
being able to nail the cases and so you
can read stuff it has meaning it's
interesting more or less
and then once certain phrases you become
familiar with certain patterns you then
go back in and really try to understand
how the cases work you now have some
experience you have something to refer
to otherwise you start from ground zero
and you're trying to
remember case endings and stuff like
that so i find i always start
to my mind i think the emphasis on
output pronunciation all those things
too early in fact
for me at any rate is unnecessary
pressure and so i prefer to sort of get
it in get it in and now okay now i'm
ready to really go for
output pronunciation it is it is a
pressure and i think it's the pressure
that easily
can floor you because if you know if
you're really trying and you're really
getting then you just can't because like
you say you can't hear it in those early
stages then
why would you carry on right so
i think yeah
i do prefer that idea of
almost the
the input the sort of absorbing the
language and kind of getting familiar
and then gaining confidence with with
that it's quite refreshing to hear
someone else yeah and people
underestimate the difficulty of
remembering things people think that
because i remember okay i learned how to
say buenos dias
you know comes
that i'm going to remember and i can say
it once or twice
then when i'm all all of a sudden
confronted with someone where i have to
say even the most basic things like
buenos dias
all of a sudden i'm frozen we
we underestimate how and that's just
something very simple like hello how are
you it's so difficult to remember things
in fact my view is that we don't
remember them we gradually get used to
them and so try and i see so many people
who've been say friends of mine who've
been studying spanish and they still
can't get past the most basic sort of
phrases and expressions because all
they're trying to do is to train
themselves to produce these phrases
whereas if they devoted the same amount
of time and effort into say initially
getting to a stage where they could
actually read a novel in
say spanish and there's you know there's
lots of tremendous audio books and then
i mean we use link to access the text
but they can use you know online
dictionaries they can import these as
ebooks there's so many different ways
that you can engage with the content and
just have this very pleasant
uh you know involvement with the
language then and then at a certain
point say okay now i'm gonna go after
you know speaking because and then
you've got some some point of reference
some experience some confidence
comprehension like how can you even talk
to someone if you don't understand what
they're saying you know so that's why
i'm kind of that way oriented
rather than
hoping in a short time
like korean i mean you can go out korean
for a year before you start speaking
because i find it very difficult to
understand people
with far less effort in ukraine i can
listen to a ukrainian history professor
talk about uh what happened a million
years ago and in korean there people are
saying stuff that i know and i can't
pick it out
yeah
it's it's true
and um
i think as well like
there was something there was a point
you said and i had a really i really
wanted to say something and it's
completely gone from my mind um
think about it i've forgotten i've
forgotten
it will come back to me all right
so
yeah but at any rate the main thing is
to motivate people
so
just a quick question here because it's
very topical
brexit
now
sitting here in canada we have this
impression of a country that's basically
split down the middle
and and those people who voted to leave
despite all that you hear so-and-so is
having buyer's remorse and they're they
were lied to himself i don't believe
that i think that the majority of those
people who voted to leave want to leave
and so even though there might be a
million people in trafalgar square and
five million people who signed a
petition basically we got if there's our
many 60 million people in the uk
they don't all vote but 30 million
people want to leave and 30 million
people want to stay
how does
or to to what extent does any of this
affect interest in language learning
that's a very good question and i think
it's
it's difficult because
for me in my kind of
social sphere if you like
i guess i was in this bubble before it
happened where
everyone you know most of my my friends
and acquaintances are quite sort of
language orientated and quite
internationally orientated so i was
seeing all of this huge support for
remain
and then the very occasional silly news
story related to the leap party you know
like oh the their bus and all the lies
on their bus and all of these these
silly stories you think oh my goodness
this is ridiculous they're never going
to win and then you see the polls coming
up and it gets close and you think oh
hang on a minute surely not this many
people can disagree and you know you do
feel very strongly about the idea that
i'm right and they're wrong and of
course that's not necessarily the case
but you it built this huge tension that
i think is still
still present after the result
definitely
but it's made me very much
it made me realize something about my
myself my own
language learning that i'd like to
mention first
it made me realize that if there's one
reason if someone said to me name one
reason why you learn languages it would
be tolerance it would be
to understand people to understand other
people that are different to me and it
gives me a level of tolerance towards
them
and
and this whole brexit thing has made me
realize that which i'm grateful for
but i do think that you know obviously
this vote is representative of how our
country feels whether or not you say
people are having the buyer's remorse
and they're feeling like oh i should
have voted to remain and i voted leave i
didn't think this would happen
it is representative that there are a
percentage there there is a percentage
of this country that do feel a strong
desire to
quote unquote make britain great again
and take our country back and i think by
that there is a feeling of
english
english english is the language and of
course this this alone in itself isn't
true even if
you take immigration out of the question
the the british isles is a multilingual
nation you know we we have
multiple languages that are spoken um
natively to to to to this this this land
so
but again i think that's unrecognized
like cornwall and wales received a lot
of eu funding a lot of support as well
in terms of language rights
what happens now
to to to those languages that we're
getting support from the eu
that's that's one side of the
the language
uh effects of brexit the other side
that's now beginning to come out is will
english be an official language within
the eu if britain leaves and i think the
answer to that is yes because you've got
countries like ireland and malta where
english is um quite quite prominent
um but you know this is this has been
questioned so
it will have an effect
on a wide scale
but i think in terms of individual
language learning
i would like to think that it would
encourage people
to
their languages to think
with as perhaps not even as a result of
brexit as a result of the
even more recent kind of um
racial tensions that seem to have
appeared since the result which i think
is
horrific
maybe people are now beginning to feel
we need to be united
with with
as native brits as people that are
immigrants to this land that live
alongside us and contribute to our
society we need to unite with people
maybe that will have a positive effect
and it will inspire people to pick up
languages to learn community languages
even more so perhaps but then of course
as i said there is a percentage of the
of the leave supporters that i believe
don't
feel that way and very very strongly
don't feel that way but i don't think
that brexit has impacted their thoughts
i think they have
possibly for a long time felt that same
way and felt that you know english only
and and and this is this is ireland you
speak english you
know so there's some various points
there's some interesting contradictions
you mentioned cornwall and wales and
i've been following it and both cornwall
and wales have not if i'm not mistaken
voted quite heavily in favor of leave
yeah yeah and since cornwall i mean
within a day two days we're saying we
still want our funding it's like
yeah they want their funding but for a
variety of things not necessarily just
for language but it's interesting those
are two areas of the uk with
marsha and wales than in cornwall but
that have a still surviving call it
regional language
they voted to leave
another interesting thing is there's
over a million brits who live
on the continent retired or otherwise or
who have homes there yes and a very
small minority of those actually bother
learning french or spanish
so those are people who actually have
an opportunity like day-to-day exposure
to
the language that surrounds them
and they still live in their little
island that's
i would say that's where the attitude
comes in of oh well if i'm going to live
in spain then i'll pick it up
right i feel like there's a certain
level of that especially especially if
if people
aren't used to
language learning and they're not kind
of obsessed like like we are then it
might be a case of oh well if i go and
live in a country i'm going to learn a
language i won't need to make an effort
which of course is incorrect i think
that's a very important point something
that maybe in a subsequent discussion we
could get into is
people underestimate
how much
i wouldn't say effort look it's effort
yeah it's time it's commitment
how much is involved in learning a
language and we have the same here
amongst immigrants who
j
in many cases whatever level of english
they arrive with that's about what
they'll have after three or four or five
years
especially with within certain groups
where there are a lot of them like the
chinese for example obviously if you are
albanian there's not too many albanians
here so you're going to have to learn
english but if you're chinese you can
live in chinese and so then the attitude
is well once i get a job
uh you know then i'll learn but in fact
they don't they don't get a very good
job because they can't speak english
very well and then in fact their
language basically plateaus
and and i've seen this like i know
people not only brits you know swedes
and others who live in spain or in
france and they kind of have sort of
feel they should try to learn but then
they go off and play golf and then they
don't worry about it and they think they
kind of can pick it up
and then they can order food in a
restaurant so they're happy so
yeah the the thing is it does take a lot
of deliberate effort
it takes a strategy
uh it you have to find out what
resources are there you need that's
where i think again i get back to this
idea of language coaches not only in
schools but even in even for you know
life long learners people like you who
can advise people direct them to the
appropriate resources motivate them
that's almost more important than
finding a tutor in
you know
toulouse
or
you know malaga
uh you'll go a few times and then you
lose interest and you won't learn much
so i i i'm a big believer in this
language coach familiar with resources
who could recommend a strategy keep
people motivated and then people have to
go and and
do it basically yeah absolutely i mean
like i said i i teach
um online and a huge part i see of my
job is also
look we're together for one hour a week
you're not going to learn spanish you're
not going to learn french in
a year you know you need to also put in
your own time and your own effort and
you know sometimes it works and
sometimes a student will be committed
they will make real progress sometimes
it doesn't and you know you can you can
generally tell um quite early on because
it's a level of motivation that you can
sense and you have to you know i'll
often work with students and kind of and
guidance and say look here are some
great resources you can use in the week
you know we've got some vocab we've
learned today put this into sentences
put it and you know in your own time
set some time aside each day so that
you're you're keeping this up and it's
not just because i think as well the the
the risk is
and i've definitely been guilty of this
too when you get a tutor
you're almost like okay i've logged on
to skype i've pressed call right teach
me
exactly you sort of almost sit back and
expect them to just tell you and absorb
nope not gonna happen no and and worse
than that not only
do does the learner become passive
saying teach me the learner says okay
i've spent the money i've devoted an
hour a week so i've done my thing
so i can't take that off i'm learning
spanish okay now i can go on and do
something something else uh i was once
at a conference in germany i was called
uh
like language language and professions
and there was a survey done of people
who were studying english let's say in
german companies because the german
employer they spent a lot of money on
language meaning they found that on
average the amount of time per week that
the professional sort of employee
learner spends on language learning
outside the hour of instruction was one
and a half hours a week
now in my experience of learning
languages one and a half hours a week is
not enough
to to really make any progress
whatsoever so so that i guess your job
and mine
is to motivate people to put in more
than an hour and a half a week into
learning their languages if they want to
get there
absolutely yeah okay well maybe we
should we can probably talk for hours
but um
we're already at 36 minutes i think
there's a lot of interesting stuff there
so i'm going to shut off the recorder
and we can have a few more minutes of
discussion okay
so thank you thank you and thank you for
all those listening and i will leave a
link to lindsay those languages in the
description box
bye bye thank you